fire enemy wrestle
[Music]
destroy so we all know that Disney
movies these days are hopelessly woke
and basically awful in every
way I'm a narcissist weird weird that's
why most people think back fondly to
like the old days of Disney they Pine
for the the
classics I understand that mentality but
the truth is that even older Disney
movies have issues the problem is that
in those films in many cases the alleged
villains are treated I think very
unfairly they get a bad rep in many
cases they are misunderstood
misconstrued I only wanted to help and
look maybe it's just my overabundance of
empathy and compassion you know it gets
me into a lot of trouble sometimes and
maybe that's what allows me to see it
this way but either way today in this
very important video we're going to talk
about Disney villains who were actually
write all
along so we'll go through five movies
number one is a Bambi wake up we have
company now first of all I've never met
a child who actually likes this movie I
don't know anyone my age who liked Bambi
growing up Bambi is one of the weakest
films in the Disney
Canon and yet it's viewed as a classic
because it happened to be released in
the ' 40s although it could have been
released last year based on fact that
the villains in this movie are the
hunters who shot Bambi's mom no Hasty SC
shooting there you are fire
away oh good shot boy good shot but they
were obviously entirely justified in
doing so first of all because venison is
delicious those Hunters I'm guessing
made some you know great venison steaks
maybe some deer jerky out of Bambi's mom
which is a fact that could have brought
Bambi some comfort and Solace if anyone
had explained it to him but they never
did
second deer populations are out of
control in this country like they wreak
havoc in ecosystems they cause 1.5
million car crashes a year including
hundreds of
fatalities so deer hunters are
performing a service and yet they've
been villainized in a movie that
generations of bored children have been
forced to watch think about this if
Bambi's mom had not been shot and killed
she may have gone on to like run into
the road one
night causing a family returning home
from dinner to Veer off into a
tree and
die whole family
dead think about that number two is Lion
King now I'm not saying that scar is the
good guy in that film I'm not justifying
what he did like killing your brother
trying to kill your nephew is is
inappropriate I don't condone it
oh God but all I'm saying is that you
know I think the character deserves a
bit more sympathy then he gets for one
thing his name is
scar okay I don't want to get into the
nature versus nurture debate but when
you name your child scar you can't
complain when he becomes a villain
especially if we have one kid that you
name Mufasa you that strong name
Mufasa the other one you named scar what
will that make you a monkey's uncle so
what did you expect also I'm not saying
the maasa deserves to be thrown off a
cliff but there's a fundamental like
moral dishonesty to maasa that I've that
I always found deeply troubling even as
a child the first time I saw it I even
said to my parents there's a fundamental
moral dishonesty in this film Mom and
Dad I said that to them and here's why
he eats his own
subjects Okay one minute they're all
celebrating the birth of his son you
know they're bringing gifts or whatever
they're cheering and the next they don't
show this in the film but Mufasa is
hunting them down and consuming them and
by the way lions eat their prey alive
that's how lions
eat that's how Mufasa treated his
subjects and then he has the audacity to
get all high and mighty towards
scar like you can understand Scar's
resentment and to make matters worse
they acknowledge it in the movie so
Simba asks his dad dad don't we eat the
anope they were just at our baby shower
and now like we eat them and that's
that's kind of not cool and Mufasa said
well son that's okay because it's part
of the circle of life when we die our
bodies become the grass and the antelope
eat the grass okay but that is not the
same thing at all that is not an even
trait so give me a break and also your
body doesn't even become grass so that's
to begin with and I'm not
holding it against a lion for being a
lion I'm just saying that there's
arguably a certain intellectual
Integrity in Scar's Outlook and behavior
that you don't find with Mufasa that's
my point number three is pocah
this is an obvious one uh the villains
in this movie are the evil white
Europeans who are portrayed as brutal
greedy barbarians oppressing the
innocent Native Americans who are all
kind and generous and so in touch with
nature that they can literally talk to
the trees good morning child somehow
everybody speaks perfect English
including the trees this is a like the
noble savage myth put the film it's also
really we talk about wokeness in Disney
films this was the beginning of Disney's
Long March into
[Music]
welness but you could argue that that
March began with the vegetarian
propaganda of Bambi but in any case the
white settlers in reality were
courageous and Intrepid Pioneers not
villains we'll build roads and decent
houses and our houses are fine you think
that only because you don't know any
better so that's an easy one number four
is Snow White now this is another case
where I'm not so much claiming that the
evil queen was wholly Justified if IED
in her actions I'm simply suggesting
that the situation is a bit more nuanced
there's some Nuance there's some
complexity okay did Snow White deserve
to be poisoned with an apple no but does
she also bear some responsibility for
eating an apple offered to her by a
random old woman who showed up at her
window laughing
manly yes absolutely all alone my pit
she never even asks like who the woman
is yes I am just the woman shows up at
the window and says hey do you want an
apple and she never says who are you
what are you why um excuse me what's the
actual Fu are you doing in my house This
Woman's walking around the forest
randomly handing out apples there's no
question she just takes it and eats it
doesn't bother washing it in the sink so
it's hard for me to feel sorry for and
for the record you should never eat
anything if the person offering it is
laughing while they hand it to you never
mind if it's an evil laugh I don't care
if it's any kind of laugh
[Laughter]
and never mind that they're at your
window in the middle of the day for no
reason not to mention the fact that the
whole Snow White fairy tale is really
about home invasion and burglary uh this
woman barges into the home of these
clearly mentally disabled old men
chimney crickets who aren't even half
her size makes herself at home what a
cute little chair now eventually the
dwarves grow attached to her so you
might say oh they're
friends no they they were they were
terrified when they first got out like
anybody would be you get home and
there's this giant like sleeping on your
bed all of your beds that she's helped
herself too of course you're going be
anyone would be scared and they were
scared but eventually this kind of
Stockholm syndrome takes effect and uh
and and they become friends and then
when she dies they put her in a glass
coffin because they somehow had a
full-size glass coffin lying around
which makes you question their motives
frankly and they display her body for
several days until a prince who has
never met her before okay shows up out
of nowhere kisses this woman who for all
he knows has been dead for days and this
is this is back when they didn't have
like the preservation of the body was
nothing was done to preserve the body
there could be some you know decomposing
I mean and he starts just kissing this
dead woman it's very dark it's a very
morbid story when you think about it
like an insane person which means the
evil queen is maybe still evil but her
action should at least be understood in
proper context and maybe you could argue
that she even was an advocate for
private property rights and that's why
she was so upset at Snow White I don't
you know that's one interpretation
number five finally is beating the Beast
now we've talked about this before I
consider it to be one of the most
important issues that I discuss it
probably deserves to be the subject of
its own documentary uh Gaston is the
quintessential villain who was actually
the hero of the story hello
Belle and I will insist on this until my
dying breath we're supposed to hate
Gaston from the beginning because why
he's manly and in good shape he eats a
lot of eggs is that his crime what has
he done wrong it's not right for a woman
to read soon she starts getting ideas
and thinking they never explain it and
the anti- gastan propaganda is laid on
thick from the very beginning but even
in spite of that it's clear who the real
protagonist is we see Gaston early in
the film what a pleasant surprise right
he's dressed to the 9 he visits Belle to
propose marriage say you'll marry me and
he's obviously an advocate of
traditional marriage and a nuclear
family he even says that he makes a
pitch for the nuclear family traditional
marriage to Bell he's explaining we'll
have six or seven dogs no Belle
strapping boys like me you know he wants
to have children he wants to have a
family it's a very lovely thing Belle
turns him down and pushes him into a mud
pit total humili
ation and yet by the end Gaston is still
willing to risk his life to rescue This
Woman This Woman Who humiliated him from
the clutches of a beast and how did
Beauty end up in that situation yeah she
initially went to the Beast Castle to
save her dad or whatever I think how did
you find me but she she had many
opportunities to escape after that
point like she could have just walked
out of me she was in in the prison cell
and then she's invited to dinner and
from that point on she doesn't go back
to the cell so she could have left
anytime anytime but she stays because
she ends up falling in love with a
non-human creature who looks kind of
like an evil water buffalo keep
something in mind
Belle didn't know that the Beast was
really a human Prince she had no idea
about that okay that's true look up on
the that's you could go back and watch
the movie that's she never is aware of
that fact that was just luck of the draw
so as far as she knew she was entering
into a romantic relationship with a
member of a of another species that's a
simple
fact now of course poor Gaston he didn't
know about any of this he didn't know
that the Beast was really a prince he
didn't know that the woman of his dreams
had fallen in love with a giant mutant
mountain goat all he knew from his
perspective was that beauty had been
imprisoned by a monster her own dad told
Gaston that who's got B locked in a
dungeon a beast a horrible monstrous
beast and so he rallies the troops he
marches off to fight for her and save
her this is the villain of the story The
Man Who ultimately gave his very life
for the woman he loved and the monster
who kidnapped a young woman is supposed
to be the one we're rooting
for that's just
wrong and I won't stand for
it so thank you for spending 10 minutes
watching this piece of content it was
obviously very important and uh well
worth your time and
mine